well let's dial in my first guest y'all
she's an actress and director and you
know her from that 70s show and orange
is the new black now she has a new
best-selling book called you and I as
mothers a Ron honest guide to motherhood
it's laura Prepon oh my gosh hello I'm
such a big fan you were so good today
you too thank you so much for having me
on
No thank you I saw your I just don't
ever see pictures I'm never in the
limelight ever and I just see you in my
head as a redhead so I'm like see and I
was like I know Laura people it is but
this is not her and I was like you're
like such a different human with dark
hair it's beautiful no thank you it's so
weird I I mean I did this because for
orange is the new black yeah and then
when we I was pregnant when we rapped
and then I couldn't change my hair color
and then I just gave birth a few months
ago and now it's a pandemic and now I
can't get my hands in my I know my roots
or I'm just like whatever so how is it
going though speaking of orange is the
new black was that any kind of prep for
a quarantine time because we you know
we're stuck in one place yeah I mean
honestly we I mean look I was already
pretty prepared I just put the whole
that my baby was coming and everything
we were already planning on isolating
and yeah I mean I don't know if orange
really prepared me but yeah is that you
know there's so many of us together all
the time but in terms of you know the
fact that I just had a baby that really
purple you know the fact that we were
already planning on isolating definitely
I think it made the transition a little
smoother yeah we we try to laugh when we
can it's hard Kelly oh my gosh no humor
has got me through many times so I'm I'm
with you with that but I hear that your
to get you through times we have
something in common you love games like
you're competitive do you play poker is
that is did I hear it right that you
play poker
that was that was another life but yes
it's time here at Cooley a life before
kids and everything I always say that
I'm like I was I was cool and I did
things I used to play so much I mean I
played in the World Series twice I was
that's crazy no I was I was obsessed I
actually I was on the cover of a poker
magazine yeah but I was totally oh
you're an actor those they are really
good at bluffing so I I did pretty well
I did pretty well I was really really
into it but now with kids I don't have
time to go sit at a card table oh my
gosh no I feel you
her new book y'all is called you and I
as mothers are on honest guide to
motherhood I feel like there is so many
books out there and so many guides for
but there's not many like I love your
title and of the vibe of it being like
raw and real and like the ups and downs
of everything I feel like everything
does it prepare you for all of that so
what made you want to open up the way
you did in your new book because you're
very honest about things that maybe
people would never tell people yeah I
honestly for me I felt like there were
all these books of our pregnancy and
there were all these books you know
leading you up to when you become a
mother but I didn't find any resources
for me once I became a mother and I was
like what about the rest of my life you
know um so for me I felt like there
really wasn't anything out there for us
and there wasn't a resource for me so I
wrote the book I was looking for I knew
a bunch of women in it to speak to all
these common themes so the reader can
find someone to relate to because we all
go through similar things even if we
there are different stages of motherhood
it's not this isn't a postpartum book
it's for mothers of all ages yeah no I
love that it's really honest I think
that that's important I also think it's
important that you surrender to speak a
mom especially a young moment of young
kids like it's really important you have
some sort of mom squad like you have
some you like or even a friend squad
they don't have to be all moms but just
to understand like where you're coming
from and to have that kind of I don't
know that bond like can you talk about
that in the book about mom squads right
yeah I mean I you know just like you
said like it's just really important
especially now with all the quarantine
in cell-by-cell
people are starting to go back out again
but nothing like we did of course with
social distancing I find that already
being a mom can feel isolating and you
know especially now with everything
we're going through with the pandemic
it's even more isolating so anything you
can do to help build that community is
so important and I write about that
because that's something I really had to
learn but now as a mother I do feel like
it's really important to have that
whether whoever that is for you whoever
your community is for you so what what
advice like what kind of advice is your
mom squad giving you like personally
like the year you've kind of struggled
with well when I had my firt you know my
my baby I just had a boy when I had my
daughter who's now about two-and-a-half
I went back to work at six weeks and I
was directing by the time she was four
months old and I remember talking to
Neela
about being a working mom and she gave
me a really cool piece of advice which
was when you talk to your kids like
about going to work she's never like oh
that sucks Mommy has to go to work she
always puts a really positive spin on it
and she's always like mommy has to go to
work isn't that awesome like she puts a
really positive thing on me so that her
children associate positivity with work
and that's some happen I thought was
really really cool especially because I
was struggling so much with going back
to work so quickly and you know another
example that kind of feeds into the mom
guilt of it all is quality over quantity
whenever friends Amber Tamblyn shared
that with me because her daughter's a
little older than mine and you can be
with your family but if you're on your
phone or fielding emails you're not
present on social media or whatever
you're doing you're not present you're
not even there so it's like quality over
quantity when you're with your family
you make it really quality time and you
really be present and are there that's
the thing that really helped me too is
just when I am with my family having
very quality time don't try to work
while I'm with my family that's
something that has really helped me a
lot
yeah yeah it's great so you open up in
the book about like speaking of being
personal for the beginning that's why I
loved about how raw and real you are cuz
I feel like sometimes that's you and far
between with people in the public eye
but you you had to make an impossible
decision during a pregnancy and and I
have known people that have had the same
scenario so what happened you know with
this situation how did you cope with it
cuz it's a that's a big thing to open up
about well what's interesting is that
when I had to make a decision because we
found out once we got into the second
trimester by the way butts usually you
know once you get into that you're like
I'm in the clear yeah found out when we
were into our second trimester that
there were some pretty devastating
health problems and that the baby was at
risk I was at risk the baby probably
wouldn't survive and that I was at risk
for carrying any longer and we really
weren't in a position to the writing was
on the wall there was nothing we could
do and my husband and I often say that
was the worst day of our lives making
that decision and it's once I went
through it I was really mad at my body
and my son but I thought I did something
to cause it which I did it I did it yeah
but you just are trying so hard to find
an answer and I found that once I went
through that I started funny about these
other women who've gone through similar
losses and nobody was talking about it
yeah but I thought that it was really
important to write about it because I
wanted other people to be able to feel
safe to share their story and the fact
that I wrote about it I can't tell you
how many people have reached out I can't
imagine how much it's helped them and
now they're able to vocalize what they
went through or they feel seen and heard
and it's something that was really hard
for me to share but I'm so glad I did
because it really helped again build
this community and made it safer for
people to talk about yeah and I I mean
I'm one who loves therapy so I just
sometimes like learning if they were
likes just saying it aloud
helps you heal like just
it out loud and not keeping it inside
and it just kind of building up like
saying it aloud helps the person saying
it just as much as somebody connecting
to the message and feeling the same way
so it's very brave and it's very cool
and you're very strong woman thank you
all right well thank you so much and
Laura's book everybody uni is mothers of
raw and honest guide to motherhood is
available now go and get it I promise
all your mom is out there a Mama's to be
it's a good one go find that one
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going